hello everyone and welcome to the first
day of the skilling open
uh the first day on the 1.5 million
dollars
champions chester and we're starting off
with a game between yanni pognish and
magnus carlson already
a crazy one at the start of the
the coverage with and uh we're gonna uh
say a few words about
the tournament as it's something we
always do when we first start covering
the tournament
so like i said skilling open i want 1.5
million dollars for the entire champions
chester
it will be a 16 player single round
robin and then
after half of them are eliminated then
we go
into the remaining eight players so for
this tournament uh the prize fund is a
100 thousand dollars with a 30
000 first prize all games are played
online on just 24
uh and the time control is 15 minutes
for all moves
uh and uh 10 second increment starting
uh with move one so
uh from the beginning of the game no
draw offers are allowed uh before move
40
uh and like i said the
the top eight players will also be
invited uh to the next event
of this uh chess chess tour so uh
without further ado let's check out the
game like i said yani palmitia versus
magnus carlsen and
nipple opens with e4 uh sorry about that
and we will have a very very interesting
line of the rue lopez called
the kosio defense and i i don't think
we've ever covered the game
uh by uh where the kosovo defense was
played other than
the game my brother brother-in-law
played against uh uh gary kasparov in
the simultaneous exhibition
uh but uh we're gonna we're gonna get to
that so knight of three knight to c6 and
bishop to b5
uh the rule lopez is on the board uh and
now
knight beat e7 knight gta e7 the cause
your defense is on the board
and if you're interested in the game uh
chronology played against kasparov
it will be the first link in the
description below
uh so knights to c3 and knight to g6 so
it's a very
uh very old line very unexplored line
you will not see it played on the on the
top level but now like i said
with uh most games nowadays being online
and pretty much everything is blitz and
rapid
players are starting to look into some
uh you know lines that would not be
suitable for for over the board
uh classical play uh sony g6 and the d4
striking in the center
e captures knight captures on d4 and now
bishop to c5 by magnus bishop the b4 is
a known move in this position
however bishop to c5 has never been
played so it is as a move
six already that we have a completely
new game
uh nepo continues we're developing
bishop to e3 adds another defender to
the knight and here
magnus prepare the bishop captures on d4
so we have bishop captures uh and now
queen to g5 putting pressure on g2 and
already
magnus is giving nipple an opportunity
to make a mistake for example
if you if you just think everything is
perfectly fine and you castle here
you will very soon lose the game uh
because just knight capture sunday for
queen captures and now the incredibly
strong knights to age four you're
threatening checkmate
and there's no way to to avoid getting
checkmated uh because if you play g3 to
block it knight f3 check picks up the
queen
as we have a nice fork here so uh only
move eight but already a lot of poison
to the position uh so nepo figures it
out he plays g3
doesn't allow any trickery and here
magnus just straights
knight captures on d4 queen captures and
now knight to e5
again going for knight f3 check uh which
will uh win the queen
so bishop back to e2 nipple gains
control of the f3 square
and now knight back to c6 by magnus
attacking nipples queen queen to c4
and now d6 preparing to bring the light
square bishop into the game
so first knight to d5 now threatening
knight c7
check to win to win the rook here and
magnus just goes back
queen back to d8 so uh this knight uh
you know came a long way he's quite the
traveler queen also uh brought back all
the way to the starting square
it's a very interesting line and here
nipple goes queen c3 kind of forcing
magnus to castle king side
the g7 pawn is under attack and if you
don't want to play something like
f6 you you castle here so magnus castles
and nipple uh castles queen side so
castle's queen side and now
rook to e8 puts pressure on the e4 pawn
but this
uh pretty much only helps nipple because
he wants to start
expanding on the king side so f3 will
help him do just that he wants to start
pushing these pawns
uh we have bishop to e6 by magnus and
now uh
bishop to b5 putting pressure on the
knight here uh you
you could you could win upon here maybe
but i don't know how
uh how good it would be for white to to
give black the open file
so here bishop back to d7 magnus decides
to defend it and
here nepo starts pushing with h4 so now
of course you want to play h5 h6 so
there's gonna be a lot of pressure here
uh but magnus plays a6 instead
so here uh nepo what nipple should do is
go back with the bishop bishop e2
uh slow down carlsen's counter play on
the queen side and then
continue pushing his pawns on the king
side however nepo goes to bishop to a4
and the magnus takes this opportunity to
open up the queen side by giving up a
pawn so here
b5 is played bishop to b3 and now
a5 so preparing to push b4 or a4 if
nepo doesn't stop it so here he plays a3
a4 was also a possibility but he decides
to go for a3
and magnus now busts open the position
by sacrificing a pawn so b4
cappers on b4 we have captures and now a
trade of knights captures captures and
captures
uh and now uh you could go for rook day
one check but
for the moment it doesn't really do all
that much king just moves and
uh well you can just trade off one of
your attackers which is not something
you want to do so magnus starts with
bishop to e6
now puts pressure on the bishop here and
nepal trades it with bishop captures
rook captures and now
queen back to c3 you could also uh play
king to b1
uh but then c5 could be annoying if the
if the white queen moves and you allow
the black queen to land on a5
white could be in trouble so instead we
have queen to c3 here nepo is preparing
to play b3 so the queen would gain
control of the a1 square so you don't
have to worry about rook to a1
and uh of course uh here we have h5
magnus
doesn't want to allow nepal to push h5
and now uh you if
black wants to continue pushing he's
gonna have to play something like g4
so here we have b3 gaining control of
the a1 square like we said and now comes
rook to g6 magnus goes after the g3 pawn
and nepo continues with f4 or grabs more
space on the king side while
uh the queen now guards the g3 pawn so
here
rook to a6 now uh if what if white plays
a slow move then magnus can play uh
queen to a8 and then you can play
something like rook to a1
so king b2 now uh queen a8 would be met
with
rook to a1 so we'd just get everything
traded along the a
file not something magnus is looking to
do so here he goes
rook to e6 again putting pressure on the
e4 pawn
and nepo defends it with queen to c4 we
have queen to f6 this is how magnus
brings the queen into the game
and nepo of course defends it with c3 so
nepo is up upon his position is great
however his king
is a bit loose here on b2 uh but okay
rook back to a8 by magnus now preparing
to shift the rook over here to put even
more pressure on the e4 pawn
and rook h to e1 uh nipple now defends
it also rook to a1 was possible to just
either trade
a pair of rooks or gain control of the a
file but okay
queen e7 now uh there could be a lot of
pressure on the pawn here
also magnus guards the c pawn here and
in some lines uh d5 is also a threat
just trying to give up a pawn to gain
access to the a3 square and this is
uh what nepo figures out and he stops
the push of the pawn with rook to d5 but
this is one of those cases
where you stopped something but but not
really so uh feel free to pause the
video here
and find the best move for magnus taking
into consideration everything i just
said
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
uh spotting the beautiful c6 idea and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's c6
uh like i said you have to get rid of
the rook and allow black to push the
pawn to d5
and uh well while the queen can capture
here the point is that uh you're
threatening everything here you're
threatening the rook uh you're
threatening if the rook moves to play d5
you're also threatening queen a7
followed by just uh
uh crushing down with the queen so while
queen captures on c6
is possible uh queen a7 is incredibly
strong here
and now it's hard for white to find the
defense there is a defense
uh rook to d2 with the idea that if
queen goes down then you can
maybe wiggle out with the king but good
luck finding this in
a rapid game where nepo is already very
low on time another thing you could do
is just capture with the rook but then
you
this is met with d5 the the queen is
under attack also queen is coming to a3
there's no stopping this it's just game
over so here nepal played rook to d4
uh he's prepared for d5 but also uh the
the pawn is now nicely defended so
magnus continues with the d5
and now queen to e2 uh keeping the pawn
defended and here magnus says okay you
can play queen a3 check but you don't
really have anything here
so here uh we have queen tafe a3 check
also c5 was a possibility just trying to
get rid of this rook but queen a3 is
sufficient because if you play something
like this captures and captures
then rook eat a6 and then again
uh sorry it's just it's just game over
uh but okay magnus goes for the
straightforward queen a3 check we have
king to c2 and now queen to a2 with
check we have king to d3 and now queen
captures on b3 and here
nepo's king is uh not uh not feeling all
that great
uh you have to play something here
nipple played queen to c2 offer the
queen trade
and magnus has uh
he can choose to move the queen anywhere
he can play queen to b5 he can play
queen to b6 queen to b7
all of these moves are great for white
and great for black and also winning for
black
however magnus played instead of all of
these moves magnus played queen to b4
and he allowed nepo to capture it with
the rook or with the pawn
now why would magnus play such a move
well it's an online game
it's played via a computer and sometimes
your mouse will just
either go crazy or you will just drop a
piece uh if you know uh
sometimes it just happens and this is
one unfortunate uh
game where it happened for magnus and it
couldn't be uh you know
it's super important game super
important tournament so it's a terrible
way to start
uh but here magnus said uh in an
interview later that he was afraid that
because he blundered the queen like this
that nipple would offer a drawing he
didn't want to draw like this so magnus
instantly resigned after he played queen
to b4
uh without even giving nepo the
opportunity to offer a draw because nepo
knew he was losing
so he probably would have offered a draw
here but magnus resigned and
uh he didn't allow it so uh not not a
great start for magnus but an
excellent start for nepo uh taking down
the world champion uh
in the first round here and uh like i
said uh the
the players are fighting to finish in
the top eight and reach the knockout
stage after two more days
of rapid chess so this was the first day
and we will have two more days and we
will show the standings now
as i don't know if i will get a chance
to show any more games from day one
uh but just in case i don't here are the
standings so after first day
uh the uh the number one player is anish
giri with four out of five points
three wins and two draws and then
followed by magnus carlsen and david
anton guiharo
who played uh incredible uh chess and as
you can see magnus
started with this terrible loss against
nepal but uh still managed to reach
second place with three and a half out
of five
uh so then we have uh with three points
wesley saw yanni palmish 11 ariana and
hikaru nakamura
with two and a half alireza first with
two points young shisht of duda le quang
liam
uh peter svidler and max team rasheela
grav with a point and a half temu rajab
and
vidi gujarati end with one point sergey
karakin now you might think okay some of
these points
some of these players should definitely
have more points but when you have
16 incredible players someone has to
have
you know not all that many points and
someone has to be last
and incredible uh start for david anton
kihara who is the
lowest seed of the tournament and
currently in third place uh
sure third shared second basically uh
with magnus carlsen
uh so yeah uh that's the the first game
we've shown
we're gonna show and uh yeah it was a
great game uh
magnus decided to go for the kosio
defense which is a very extremely rare
and
nepo really took his time trying to
trying to fight it but in the end
magnus was winning but then this just
happens
and we have to get used to it i mean the
more games that we're
we're going to have online uh the more
mouse slips there will be and we already
discussed uh how to deal with mouse lips
in the previous video where we had the
mouse slip
so we're not going to cover it here but
as usual i'm always interested in in
your thoughts
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank michael kelber
uh boris malinka which hector coronado
todd victor and killian krebs for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the scaling
open
checking up uh on your wonderful
suggestions and uh whatever else happens
in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day